herr präsident meine damen und herren
die bundesregierung hat sich entschieden
von deutschland aus das klima zu retten
und dafür die energieversorgung unseres
landes aufs spiel zu setzen wie beim
atomausstieg oder bei der massenhaften
aufnahme von migranten befinden wir uns
wieder mal auf einem deutschen sonderweg
allein
dabei pfeifen es die spatzen von allen
dächern die deutsche energiewende ist
gescheitert ein gutachten von mckinsey
kam im september dieses jahres zu dem
ergebnis dass die deutsche
energieversorgung unsicheren zeiten
entgegengeht
fast alle ziele der energiewende sind
verfehlt worden
die versorgungssicherheit werde nach dem
atom und kohle ausstieg nicht mehr
gewährleistet sein
zugleich kommt der windkraftausbau zum
erliegen
die zahl der erteilten genehmigung sei
in den ersten quartal drei quartalen
2009/10 regelrecht zusammengebrochen
klagte der bundesverband der energie und
wasserwirtschaft am 8
ein grund für den rückgang ist das neue
ausschreibungsverfahren das im
billigsten anbieter bevorteilt die
subventionierte lizenz zum gelddrucken
es damit versehen
[Applaus]
außerdem verhindern bürgerinitiativen
immer häufiger windkraftprojekte sie
kämpfen nicht nur gegen die
umweltzerstörung die massenhafte
speicherung von vögeln sondern auch
gegen die gesundheitsgefährdung durch
infraschall scheibchenweise wird der
mindestabstand reduziert bis auf 350
meter sind die windmühlen schon einen
hohen häuser heran gerückt
wer die welt retten will meine damen und
herren kann auch petit essen wie die
gesundheit der anwohner natürlich keine
rücksicht nehmen
immobilien folien massiv an wert wenn
windräder in der nähe stehen
leider stehen sie natürlich nicht im
prenzlauer berg oder in münchen
schwabing
es sind immer die anderen die den preis
zahlen die bulls die politische
windkraft lobby versucht inzwischen
kritiker als rechte zu denunzieren
hier entsteht eine art neue
dolchstoßlegende
aber auch dieser krieg krieg ist an der
front verloren nämlich an den
unerbittlichen fronten der physik und
der ökonomie
obwohl der ausbau der windkraft absehbar
endet hält die regierung nicht nur am
atomausstieg bis 2022 fest sondern
rechnet mit einer steigerung des
stromverbrauchs bis 2030 bundesregierung
und automobilindustrie versprechen bis
dahin eine million elektro auto
ladestation
woher aber soll der strom kommen für die
elektroautos wenn grundlastfähige
kraftwerke abgeschaltet werden und womit
sollen wir in zukunft heizen
vielleicht ist die bundesregierung ja
der meinung die menschen werden sich
künftig an ihrem guten gewissen erwärmen
liebe freunde meine damen und herren
wenn die viertgrößte wirtschaftsnationen
der erde sich entschließt das energie
fundament ihrer wirtschaft zu beseitigen
und durch eine alternative zu ersetzen
die vorsichtig formuliert nicht
besonders stabil ist dann erwarte ich
abbitte öffentliche debatten darüber
dann erwarte ich redeschlachten um das
für und wider im parlament dann erwarte
ich dass die these vom menschlichen
anteil am klimawandel unter den
größtmöglichen klassifikations druck
gesetzt wird
denn wir tun wahrscheinlich etwas
unumkehrbares aber das thema ist
dermaßen ersatz religiös aufgeladen dass
die frage richtig oder falsch keine
rolle mehr spielen sie ist vollkommen
verschüttet unter den kriterien gut und
böse
begriffe wie klimaleugner kursieren auch
gestern wieder in diesem hause hat sich
die vernunft verarschen wird ein
wissenschaftler der sich der klima
hysterie verweigert spielt mit seiner
karriere
die merkel jahre werden als eine
bleierne zeit in erinnerung bleiben in
den öffentlichen debatten im seinem der
hyper moral ausstieg wurden am 20
november und 12 uhr mittags sind nach
angaben der strombörse von den 77
gigawatt stromverbrauch in deutschland
64 gigawatt durch konventionelle und
atomkraftwerke geliefert worden
64 von 77 meine damen und herren ich
frage mich wie sie unser land mit strom
versorgen wollen wenn diese 64 gigabyte
einmal abgeschaltet sind
an drei tagen im juni am 6 1225 war das
deutsche stromnetz akute unterversorgung
solche unterdeckungen müssen durch strom
aus dem ausland ausgeglichen werden
eine sprecherin der energiewirtschaft
beteuert zwar die gefahr eines blackouts
habe nicht bestanden
aber was ist wenn 2022 die
atomkraftwerke vom netz gehen
was passiert wenn sogenannte
klimaaktivisten ist tatsächlich schaffen
ein großes kohlekraftwerk lahmzulegen
haben sie sich einmal ausgemalt was ein
tagelanger black aus bedeuten würde
denken sie doch nur an die abertausenden
menschen die ihn fahrstühlen
eingeschlossen werden
und solche lifte haben nur in
amerikanischen action film eine klappe
über wie man sie verlassen kann ich will
nicht den teufel an die wand malen aber
ein blackout ist weit wahrscheinlicher
als die von ihnen beschworene
klimakatastrophe dass es ausgerechnet
eine physikerin ist die unsere
energieversorgung aufs spiel setzt ist
zwar komisch sollte uns aber nicht
irritieren es war ein schauspieler der
den kalten krieg gewonnen hat und
offensichtlich nimmt sich frau merkel
daran ein beispiel meine damen und
herren wenn die lage wirklich so schlimm
ist wenn wir wirklich demnächst auf
diesen schönen planeten gekocht werden
dann müssen zuerst sie sich wohl der
einsicht öffnen dass der populistische
atomausstieg ein irrweg war es wäre
geradezu eine hübsche list der vernunft
wenn die heilige kreta zu dieser
erkenntnis würde bei ihnen nicht das ist
mir schon klar aber wer wirklich etwas
für das klima tun will der muss seinen
blick auf die bevölkerungsexplosion in
afrika lenken die bundesregierung
hat vor kurzem den soli quasi
abgeschafft wir hätten nichts dagegen
gehabt ihn in einen investitionsfonds
für afrika umzuwandeln
wir hätten dem zugestimmt wenn sie im
gegenzug die grenze geschlossen und die
klammheimlichen asylanten flüge
eingestellt hätten wir sind uns der
tatsache bewusst dass uns das schicksal
afrikas nicht gleichgültig sein kann nur
gilt eben auch hier die maxime dass
politik sich an den realitäten
orientieren muss nicht an formen
wünschen die bevölkerung afrikas wächst
derzeit alle zwölf tage um 100 millionen
menschen
die knapp zwei millionen migranten die
wir seit 2015 aufgenommen haben sind
dort in einem halben monat nach geboren
worden
dagegen hat einen direkt in afrika
ausgegeben oder noch besser investierter
euro
nach den worten des
entwicklungshilfeministers gerd müller
die 30-fache wirkung wie eine in
deutschland eingesetzt war
die bevölkerungsexplosion meine damen
und herren ist das größte problem
unseres planeten
übrigens auch für die umwelt es würde
ein mal zeit dass frei dsv future auf
die bedeutung des ungebremsten
bevölkerungswachstum für die
klimaerwärmung hinweisen
aber er schafft die bundesregierung den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland ab als
dass ihr der begriff geburtenkontrolle
in afrika über die lippen kommen
denn das wäre ja wieder rassismus
96,5 des weltweit ausgestoßenen
kohlendioxids sind natürlichen ursprungs
von den restlichen 3,5 prozent stammen
2,2 prozent aus deutschland
das ist wenigstens nicht umstritten
selbst wenn unser land morgen zu
existieren aufhörte wären die
auswirkungen auf die welt temperatur
praktisch nicht nachweisbar und dafür
setzen sie alles aufs spiel
dafür machen sie eine energiewende und
dafür ruinieren sie unsere autoindustrie
und die maschinenbauindustrie
meine damen und herren das ist keine
zukunft die wir mit ihnen gehen wollen
deswegen werden wir dagegen kämpfen und
auch gegen diese regierung die das
versucht danke